hi this is a Sadashiva pipe from science
mission so today we have a dr. Joseph
Doherty associate professor department
of genetics and Department of Psychiatry
with us so he's from Washington
University School of Medicine signed
Louise so Joe has won several awards to
his credit he won Howard Hughes Medical
Institute pre-doctoral fellowship k99 ro
Sheraton autism and investigating cell
types for CNN's disorders so route 28
summit in neurobiology Award for
Excellence
he was highlighted one of the genome
technologies up-and-coming investigator
in 2012 so in addition he also has won
several grants and has published many
papers in high-impact peer-reviewed
journals so welcome to Joe yes can you
please talk about yourself your
background education give you an update
on like what you are like what you do
sure yeah
so I've had the lab here at Wash U for
eight years now so I'm just grabbing
myself as a new professor but I guess
that's not true so much anymore okay my
original interest in science actually
came in through psychology as an
undergraduate sort of biological
psychology from a small undergrad
institution in Missouri call him a
Freeman state and I was very interested
in how the I think what drew me into
science was sort of interested in how
the mind worked but I wanted to be able
to do methods that were
physiological and you could sort of test
for years questions so for graduate work
I went and did molecular neuroscience
with Dan gush wind at UCLA and the early
days on my arrays and high-throughput
transcriptomics and I worked there on a
lot of defining differential gene
expression and neural stem cells and
genes that regulated proliferation
versus differentiation which I think was
interesting and a great experience but
by the end of it I realized I wanted to
move back
up towards questions of things that were
involved in the mind so for a postdoc I
went worked with NAT Heintz at the
Rockefeller University I was really
excited about that because it gave me
the opportunity to take kind of these
skills I'd built in transcriptomics in
genomics but actually take them up into
a functioning brain because Nats lab at
the time was developing these methods
for doing cell type specific and vivo
profiling I'll actually mentioned some
of those in the talk as the starting a
little bit of the starting point and
excuse me for coughing up that kind of a
bad cold I've got some tea going so
hopefully he's been restrained so the
mouths are sort of them out right level
organism for me where I could do had the
control to be able to do you know
well-designed experiments of cause and
effect in terms of how genes regulate
behavior and how and but also was you
kind of a high complicated enough
organism you would have things like
behavior and cognitive processes going
on more so than kind of cell culture
work so that kind of everything where I
settled and then for my lab what we
focus on is a mix of different things so
we're trying to understand broadly how
genetic mutation changes circuits in the
brain in a way that results in
psychiatric disease or disease focus is
mostly autism we do a mix of mouse
modeling of genes that cause autism
focusing on those that come out of high
impact studies from collaborators sure
there's a regulate transcription or
translation and then on the other side
of lab we do a lot of technical
development around understanding how
transcription translation or regulate in
the brain bringing you methods online
focusing on cell types we think are
important for disease so today I'll be
talking mostly about some of that
technical development work and how it
led us to discoveries of local
translation and astrocytes and some of
the translation regulation work we've
been doing can you talk a little bit
about your lab your last terrains post a
give it like ID on like how is your lab
like how main quarter well we're about
15 people right now it's a mix of C we
have two postdocs and
instructor at the moment at kind of the
senior level two technicians in a
programmer as terms in terms of staff
and then about half seven or eight
graduate students depending on how you
count the ones that I jointly mentor
it's a really good group of people it's
probably you know I try and structure
the lab so that I get to interact with
everybody as much as possible because
that's what I enjoy about science is
interacting with other scientists and I
kind of view the people in my lab as my
long-term collaborators that I get to
work with so I try and meet with
everybody kind of weekly to hear what
they're up to
I'll either do it one-on-one or kind of
a mix of one-on-one or small groups who
are working on related topic so that can
be good information sharing across teams
working on related projects yeah we do a
mix of sort of everything from molecular
to computational to behavioral work most
people do kind of more than one things
that's important to have especially if
you're training to have really a
multi-faceted experience in in biology
because it requires expertise in so many
different domains even if your career is
going to take you really largely into
one of those having some exposure during
your training to each of them I think
really helps make you a strong
collaborator going forward and a
well-rounded scientist overall I think
the mission in the lab is really to put
it both produce really good science but
also to really produce very strong
scientists so I focused on providing the
good training experience for the
students in the lab trying to teach them
how to run a project independently and I
view most of what we do is really you
know I'm pitching ideas to them they're
petunias to me and I think that
happening is there's a hybrid of those
ideas coming from them coming from me
and regarding like you know the research
is a long-drawn process it takes years
and all those things to publish a paper
so that is always ups and downs so keep
them motivated so make sure that they
come to the lab and the things and
always in a positive mental state right
sometimes you have two periods graduate
school especially where things just
partial work for a while like way
six months in graduate school one point
hybridizing what I thought with these
custom micro arrays with precious RNA
that I had to keep it would take me like
three weeks or four weeks to do this
long differentiation protocol to harvest
this trace amount of RNA and then label
it and I'd scan this slide it would be
blank so I thought it as hybridizing
months and let's have reasons customer
raised and not getting anything until I
think finally one day I I stay in a
slide with Dappy and realized that
there's absolutely nothing on the slide
and I just spent six months trying to
hybridize blank saying that I'd gotten
from a collaborator so I mean these
tragedies in science happen and I think
what has to keep you going
first I just try and hire people that
are very excited about doing science to
begin with you know you have to be
internally driven to take on this career
to take on these challenges and patient
and excited about the next experiment
and then I try and always make sure that
people have a couple of different things
to work on so that when you hit a wall
in one area you still gonna have
movement the other because I think it's
really kind of always have to you have a
kind of a balance of projects that are
high and low risk so you have something
going on that's positive and then I
guess the third thing is to uh you know
get time away from the lab to you know
when things aren't we working it's a
good time to get well and go take a
break and just go read for a while go
think for a while and just let's try it
something you know if they really once
you've tried an experiment two or three
times with minor variations it's not
going to work that way it's really let's
try something completely different
coming up on a completely different
angle
hopefully that helps keep people
motivated and excited about what they're
doing and regarding hobbies like I know
you're busy with all the projects so
many people in the lab and all so how do
you balance that work life thing like
what are the things you do I've got two
elementary school-aged kids at home and
when I try and structure my free time
it's around other days that they're off
so yesterday that they were out of
school for a parent-teacher conferences
so I took them skiing at this little
local Missouri ski resort and it's not
great skiing in Missouri it's kind of
like skiing on mashed potatoes is really
stuck to me but it was really fun so I
like to do those
kind of outdoorsy things with my kids I
wouldn't have time I read I don't know I
did I have a lot of different interests
I like to try different restaurants and
singleness there's a pretty good food
scene
goes to music okay you know it's good
it's important to take time away from
the lab to and recharge and regarding
mentorship like like that's the
important part of the whole research
aspect you view it like can you talk
something about this mentorship people
help you and how you plan on doing it to
your students training people it's
interesting it's an interesting kind of
training because you you're I think a
lot of students come in kind of focused
on the methods and learning methods and
techniques and those are important for
sure but they're just a foundation to
what we're really trying to train you in
which is how to you know move into an
area define a key question and design
the experiments and execute the
experiments to address that question
because the actual methods that you
learn I mean there's so many things that
can think back on a graduate school that
I spent months and months mastering
they're not completely obsolete like I
learned how to build a robot a microwave
network but learn how to read and think
about science is a skill that can last
forever so I do a lot of I usually do
that through writing a lot with students
I have everybody write grant proposals
like training fellowships as a way of
kind of guiding them through thinking
about the process of it ahead of time
it's a lot of I don't know a lot of
meeting and discussion I try and prompt
them to try and figure out how to get
them to think of the next experiment on
their own and by the end when I'm hoping
you know early on often I'm sort of
pitching experiments to them early in
the graduate career but by the end of
the career the the ideas that are kind
of coming into my office excited about
the next experimental they want to do
and I'm just they're sort of like oh you
you know helping them guide their
thinking a little bit if you thought
about this control of that control
you know but that really trying to teach
them how to kind of be reading the
literature thinking about the next
experiment on their own going asking for
help when you need it and training where
you need it but really you know teaching
them to be independent is the goal
overall okay now going back to the
research like talking about you or some
of the projects going and you can start
presenting once you are into oh okay
well I already kind of like talked about
a big picture I'm excited about
everything the lab is doing okay always
we have one set of people working on
mutations in mice for genes we think
cause disease in humans a big focus
there is the Williams syndrome locus
which is a 20-18 deletion but are the
current dominant or the dumb and
hypotheses right now is that it's a
couple of transcription factors in there
they're meeting in the phenotype and
it's an interesting phenotype because
you can get changes in structural
motivation depending whether you get
deletions or duplications in this region
so we're trying to model that mice and
understand the molecular level what the
consequences are and a behavioral level
on the technical development side I
think I'll be talking a lot about that
the translation regulation stuffs now so
preview that the other kinds of
technical development that we're doing
is cell type-specific
epigenetic profiling methods that we've
been developing there's two preprints we
just put up on that it's called the
calling cards methodology since a single
cell version targeted version those are
up on bio archive my name is Onan but
the lead authors are Alex chemic and
Arnab luteal so if you want to look
those up and hear more about that
project if you go check out that work
we're also widely collaborative there's
almost no collaborations that could ever
possibly discuss in yeah and this you
know since we do a lot of technology to
vote we're always happy to share
whatever we're developing this is a lot
of collaborations because of that and
then there's this translation dependent
regulation methods of been developing
that I'll talk about now
oh go ahead you can share them little
bit slide I keep looking over there
that's where they are for me let's see
click the shareable thing daddy okay you
guys see the screen now do you see my
mouse when it's over the screen does
that work isn't yeah yeah I can see that
okay excellent so today I'll try and
spend the next kind of 30 minutes or
thirty five ish minutes talking about
three little stories in the lap that are
around new methods we developed to study
a translation regulation in the brain
how we came to be interested in that and
then what we ended up discovering some
of the things we expected to discover
and some of the things that were
surprises to us is the sound okay - yeah
alright so as I kind of alluded to
earlier I'm interested in in how
different cell types expressed different
genes in the brain so as a
neuroscientist and training I'm always
required to show at least one image from
qahal it's in the contract so here's my
qahal image this is an image from the
cerebellum and I just put it here to
illustrate that even in a relatively
simple structure like the cerebellum you
have a variety of very your a wide
variety of morphological diversity I can
orally equally diverse functions across
these different cell types in the brain
yet every one of these cell types has an
identical copy of the genome so how do
you get this diversity of morphology and
function you do it by choosing what
fraction of the genome you express so
every cell type has a unique gene
expression profile at the beginning of
my postdoc has very interested in
understanding which genes are defining
that each cell type particularly for
those cell types that might be important
for psychiatric disease as you have
thousands of cell types in the brain but
presumably only a subset of those are
really driving the circuits that disrupt
brain function psychiatric disorders so
how do you measure gene expression in a
complex mix so these this is not actual
data this is just a cartoon
obviously but the problem when you're
trying to analyze a mix of different
cell types is that here cartoon is sort
of green triangles for neurons or for
after sight and blue circle indicates is
that whenever you the most methods to
measure gene expression traditionally
would be grinding up the school tissue
and measuring the RNA in bulk from it
and you can see sort of that you would
end up getting a mix of RNAs from the
different cell populations so how would
you measure this in specific cell types
what my postdoctoral lab particularly
Miriam Heyman who was working with Paul
GREENGUARD and now it's the time what
they kind of settled on was this idea
that if you really want to purify the
mRNA from those cell types you don't
have to purify the cell types themselves
which could be challenging an adult
brain rather if you just pull the
ribosomes out of those cells any mRNA
that's being translated from in those
cells would be captured and he could
then kind of look at the cell
type-specific gene expression that way
then so they developed this method
called trap translating ribosomal
affinity purification
we're in use mouse genetics to drive GFP
expression in a specific cell type by
using a cell type specific promoter
here's an example from serotonin neurons
we did and what you drive instead of
normal GFP is GFP fuse to arrive is oval
protein so on one hand you get
fluorescent labeling that you can see
and confirm the expression but the other
hand you also get an affinity tag on the
ribosomes and so if you use antibodies
to GFP you can pull the mRNA out of a
lysate even after licen an entire mouse
brain you can select for the mRNAs that
came from the cell population and
enriched for those yeah and sort of a
standard comparison we often do is just
comparing to the pre IP here the
surrounding tissue so what are what RNAs
were specifically enriched in this
population versus all others the United
Center
so the early years of my lab were
devoted to taking my side made in Nats
lab those that I thought were important
for psychiatric disease particularly
like neuromodulatory populations and
glia so
and I had a mousseline for each cell
type I was interested in and we would
try and go in and sort of pick a
phenotype we thought was associated with
that mouse with that cell type and try
understand that that cell types gene
expression I mean determine whether we
could use that to identify genes that
regulated that phenotype so here's an
example here's the last of those studies
we were doing in 2018 and some reports
where we did the noradrenergic neurons
of the coeruleus this is a the main
producers of norepinephrine for the
forebrain and we could successfully
target them and profile them this just
shows an enrichment of sort of the known
genes that we thought were expressed in
those noradrenergic neurons who saw that
good depletion of gweal genes but we
also identified hundreds of new genes
that were rich in these cells and
previously characterized kind of one of
the surprises that came out of that was
actually this locus was very sexually
dimorphic so there was also a lot of
gene expression differences between
males and females
far more than compare other comparison
cell types and I won't go into detail
because it's published there but we
picked out sort of one gene that we
thought might be important for
controlling these cells that was
sexually differently expressed it's a
ep-3 receptor and showed that female
brains specifically responded to agonize
to this at a much higher level the males
and we can modulate Mouse behavior in a
sex specific way so that's the kind of
work we've been doing around stem cell
types in the genes within them and when
I first started this work I was sort of
you know the fact that we had to purify
the ribosomes in the cells was one step
away from what I usually think of this
gene expression right it was [ __ ] we
weren't really looking at transcription
per se we're looking at the second step
of translation and initially I kind of
thought oh this is a bug you know that
we were stuck not quite getting
transcription but over time I came to
realize that actually could be a feature
instead is that you know gene expression
really is in two steps you have
transcription in the nucleus which makes
the mRNA but then you have also this
translation to make the protein in the
cytoplasm and if you think about
something like a neuron that has an
incredibly elaborate morphology
huge processes that it can be even micro
undreds of microns to millimeters away
from the cell body yet you only have one
source for the mRNA in the nucleus that
means that there must be substantial
regulation the level of translation to
actually make the right amount of
protein in the right places to make for
a functioning style and a cell that can
adapt to its environment and especially
in the advent of a lot of sort of single
cell sequencing RNA sequencing methods
coming out those can do a lot much
faster job of identifying cell
type-specific
expression profiles since they're
untargeted methods but kind of a unique
niche we still had was understanding how
translation is regulated across
different cell types in the brain so
today I'm going to talk about our
efforts to think about trap not just a
way I do it with gene expression
profiling but a way of specifically
profiling translation and what we
learned out of that in terms of how
translations regulated the nervous
system both with some surprises and some
expected results all right guys I should
probably meet at the microphone before I
did that vicious this is the joy the joy
and travails of having small children is
our little viral incubators now since I
had kids have been sicker than I ever
was before having kids right so just a
reminder of what translation looks like
because this will come back up later is
that on a transcript you have a coding
sequence which is the part that you
actually think of as being translated
protein it starts with the start codon
and ends with the stop but on
translation occurs with a small
ribosomal subunit arting in this five
prime untranslated region scammy until
it finds something looks like I start
going on recruiting a large subunit
translating through the coding sequence
and then the two separate at the stop
codon typically to find recruitment to
the start codon there's often sort of a
sequence specific context like a Kozak
sequence that helps identify it now I'll
come back up later so how do you access
SS translation well if you want to know
something about the levels of
installation and kind of simple systems
like Easter subculture there's a classic
method people used to do called
ribosomes book printing where you would
stall ribosomes on on the transfer cycle
hexamine in a lysate and then they do
this thing that's a little terrifying to
molecular biologists which is that you
would then take your precious sample and
digest it with RNA s-- thus destroying
your RNA but the key here is that the
ribosome physically protects a fragment
of that RNA giving you a little 32
nucleotide or 28 to 30 nucleotide
footprint of where the ribosome was
physically sitting now one of the
secrets to modern genomics it's kind of
a tongue-in-cheek joke is that you take
a method from the 70s or 80s and add the
word seek to it I had to create a new
method and this is what ungoliant
Weisberg did in the really nice series
of studies are from 2009 actually to
this day but like the real several
sentence kind of in major journals from
2009-2011 kind of established and showed
the power of this method of kind of
adapting this to sequencing so now you
can vert these little fragments into the
sequencing library and you can align
that back to the mRNA and see exactly
where ribosomes were at the moment of
what you're translating so we were
interested in what we could learn in
neuroscience using these methods and I
usually start most experimental series
with something that's a bit simple and
then try and build up from them so the
very first thing that it would simply
try and replicate the methods that they
applied in ES cells and East to tissues
from the CNS to see whether or not we
can kind of see the same kinds of things
that they had seen so in their what they
had seen was that there's a wide range
of translational efficiencies across
transcription I'll come back to that
later and also a variety of different
proteins being produced from the same
sequences so our first experiment was
simply to take cultured cortical neurons
so we could start from cell cultures
they did and do ribosome footprint and
RNA seek from the same cells and it
seemed like it was working so we got the
ribosome footprints were only in the
coding sequence as you'd expect compared
to the RNA seek which covers the whole
transcript
just as they saw this is sort of an
initial surprise innovative it's
actually quite a lot of ribosomes
already on the five prime UTR and we
were able to reproduce that in these
mixed neuronal cultures the first thing
you can look at with this kind of data
is to determine whether or not there are
certain transcripts that really are
dynamically regulated in a way of sort
of having a higher amount of translation
you'd expect by chance you know one of
those advantages and regulation at the
level of translation is that for a given
amount of transcript you can actually
make more or less protein than the cells
can make more or less protein in a
regulated way and this does define by
measure called translation efficiency I
kind of prefer the term ribosome density
but ter translation efficiency is a
standard in the field and it's simply
dividing the number of ribosome counts
by the number R and they seek counsel
the same transcript and you can end up
sort of identifying transcripts that
have a lot more ribosomes or a lot less
ribosomes than you'd expect by chance
and thus are making more or less protein
even though at an RNA seek level they
look more or less identical so as
they've done in ES cells and neurons we
just first kind of look at the
distribution of these values in a log
scale and you can see that you know if
neutral is about two ribosome footprints
for transcript that we're seeing here
you can have individual transcripts
there ten feeling more ten fold less
translated than you'd expect clearly
super low we've translated this into the
brain and a way that I don't have time
to talk about today but basically
comparing trap to nuclear RNA you can
see that that same spread occurs across
cell types and vivo in the brain and
even some transcripts beam up to a
thousand times more or less translated
than you'd expect given their RNA
abundance and Meekers going back to the
in vitro studies we next wanted to ask
to what extent is this regulated by
stimuli so we know that gene expression
is strongly regulated by things like
neuronal activity and a very simple
manipulation of classical emulation to
look at that with the sledgehammer first
experiment is to hit a cultured group of
neurons with KCl which depolarizes the
whole culture kind of stimulant
stimulating a lot of firing activity and
compare that to unstimulated culture
this classic manipulation is known to
induce transcriptional changes like
induction of the immediate early genes
that's we usually also look at what
happens to translation
first looking at our tasty just in terms
of the numbers of trips and all the Dean
Lister published here in this reference
at the bottom if you're interested so
I'm not hiding them they just make your
boring slides if you wouldn't be guilty
you know 1200 or so genes upregulated
about 600 unregulated this include many
other things that you would expect to
see in a transcriptional study in terms
of response to depolarization and neural
cultures when we looked at the ribosome
footprint in data we actually saw an
even greater change so this says that
there's more things changing at the
level of translation than a
transcription alone and that's mediated
by a subset that are dynamically
changing their translation efficiency in
response to stimulation overall the
there is pretty good correspondence
what's happening in RNA seek and our
opportunity for looking across all genes
in terms of their full change
um so most genes along the line would be
things that are going up in both RNA
level on the ribosome and off the
ribosome in parallel in a concordant way
there are squared you know it fits about
half about you know basically half of
the data is explained in what's on the
ribosome is explained by changes in RNA
seek but that leaves about half being
left to translation regulation and
there's individual genes red or yellow
on that don't change RNA levels at all
but but change specifically they're
loading onto ribosomes as shown in this
method these is that same data shown as
heatmaps
proteins up regulated down regulator
changing to e and a couple example genes
of that kind of pattern like that red
gene here F th one RNA seek is not
changing but the amount on the ribosomes
is going up and that's reflectively
change at TD so this is basically a
transcript that seems to be recruiting
ribosomes in response to stimulation and
we also see the opposite this is some
strange cyclin homolog relatively
unstudied ra seeks not changing but
things are it seems to be losing
ribosomes in response to stimulation so
this means that translation is quite
dynamically regulated in the nervous
system and in low represents this
additional layer of underappreciated
changes in gene expression so the next
sort of vignette I wanted to tell you
guys is about astrocytes and their local
translation so I love astrocytes by
working
school was on neural stem cells which in
their brain turned out to be sort of a
sub for master site a radial glia and
i've always thought about thought of
them as a key neuromodulator and
regulator of activity in the brain and
so when we as postdocs back in the
heights lab we're dividing the brain up
into different cell types to go after I
took neuromodulatory populations like
serotonin more different producing ions
as well as bleeeh like astrocytes in
rods so the story I'm gonna tell adays
comes from two students in the lab who
really led this part of it Chris East
acres and Rebecca lingo who both just
defended recently moved on and it comes
from first this idea of you know kind of
eyes as alluding to earlier this very
complex cellular morphology that you
have in neurons compared to like a
lymphoblast cell and rounds down here
you have these long elaborate processes
yet all of your mRNA has to come from
the nucleus but what so how do you you
know create proteins and get them where
you need them given this complicated
cell but mrna only coming from one place
and on Stewart particularly in the 1980s
showed by M that you could identify what
looked like ribosomes right at the base
of these dendrites out in at the base of
these spines and these dendrites far
from the nucleus this suggestion that
there was a role for sort of a regulated
local production of proteins to enable
the formation of these synapses this is
interesting because it's known that
synapses to allow for learning and
memory or at least changes in synaptic
strength you need new protein synthesis
so this suggested that if you want to
strengthen particular synapses one way
to do it is to locally produce the
proteins that you need there to make it
first harness Turner one of my favorite
classic experiments kind of
demonstrating this phenomenon came from
Aaron Schumann way about actually over
20 years ago now it's still a very
elegant experiment so there's this form
of synaptic plasticity
called well this is chemically induced
long term potentiation or LTP
so with these application of BDNF you
can see that you get a an ink
in the field potential over time and
what she showed in the set of
experiments was that you could slice off
the dendrites away from the cell body
[Music]
physically removing them and still get
this increase in in LTP even though they
have no access to the nucleus so you
that the sensible room is independent
however if you added in this of myosin
an inhibitor of translation the synapses
were no longer capable of doing this
independently or at least the synaptic
layers no longer capable of doing it
independently which says that look some
kind of local translation in that layer
was required for this long-term
potentiation right so we wanted to be
able to kind of look so we were curious
about what particular mRNAs were found
at the synapse this has been studied in
a few parts of the brain before like
this where you could physically slice
away the tender X from the cell body
when most of the brain's not organized
that way is organized in a way that the
cell bodies and entering through densely
intermingled so there wouldn't be a
minimum but sort of physically trying to
separate them and we wondered if there's
a way we can adapt trap to this though
this is just a linnekar tuna
trap and a remind you that I've
mentioned I have received royalties
related to travel of house so what
Rebecca said have to do was to see
whether or not we could use trap to get
specifically at these synaptic all
ribosomes bound mRNAs from different
subpopulations the brains Anna what a
layer of cell type specificity to
studying local translation neurons and
looking back at the different trap lines
that remain in the past here's one for
those Mackenzie neurons in the
cerebellum while most of the signal is
in the cytoplasm in the ER near the
nucleus you could see when you crank the
gain in the microscope that these trap
lines that have GFP labeled ribosomes
also contributed little GFP positive
puncta out in the 10 tracks so we
thought that it might be possible in
trying to harvest the ribosomes
specifically from this layer so there is
an old method from the 80s and old
biochemical methods the 80s
whereby you can fraction eight the brain
into a synaptic fraction so this is a
synaptic neuron was the
variation that we were using so you use
a density do you generally homogenize
the brain use density senator creation
to identify a fraction that contains
these fragments of cells that have a pre
and postsynaptic opposition with
membrane-enclosed and they've been shown
for a long time that these things were
translationally competent if you
stimulated them and add radio label
nucleotide they take it up and
synthesize the protein so it's sort of
an in vitro way of looking at local
translation however it has no particular
cellular specificity in those fractions
like I was saying the way of modern
genomics is to take a nice method from
the nineteen eighties 80s and add the
word seek to it so we we took that same
method and tried to start sequencing
these fractions furthermore if we
combine this with a line a trap line
that labels specific neuronal classes we
should be able to isolate ribosomes by
traps specifically from this fraction
that were contributed by just one type
of neuron in the brain so that would
allow us to disentangle sort of a dense
mash of lots of different cell types
mixed together with lots of different
dendrites and specifically enriched for
those ribosomes coming from just one
cell type allowing us ask the question
of which cell types put which
transcripts at their scent on ribosomes
in the other synapses so when we start
experiments I usually start with the
simple ones so we do just a pan to run a
line in cortex we picked this line
because it you know when we're
optimizing biochemistry we want to start
with nor adrenergic neuron where there's
only 1,200 in the brains we had pen pen
neuronal but also in the cortex which is
one of these areas where their cells are
densely intermingled because the local
translation hadn't really effectively
been studied before I'll just make a
note also we have this people interested
in astrocytes we have this astrocyte
line the labels every astrocyte the
brain with with the trap construct as
well so that actually terms of the
neuron like findings will refer you to
Rebecca's paper she also had another one
just come out in neuro last month
comparing different cell types one of
the things we were intrigued by is we
kind of do
opting out this method working in
neurons was what's going on with the
astrocytes so astrocytes are originally
thought of as a support cell in the
brain they make up this broad synteny of
cells that basically cover the entire
brain and the matrix feel it physically
kind of making contact with every my
background of the brain more or less
they're evenly dispersed from one
another
individually they have a beautiful
elaborate morphology I think this is
sort of underappreciated because many of
the classical stains for astrocytes like
such as GF ap would only label a large
calibers processes but if you actually
fill them you can see they have lots of
fine processes and it started us
wondering whether or not they had to
deal with the same challenges as neurons
to in terms of having localized
photosynthesis of protein and they have
a variety of important functions in the
brain that really makes them we think of
them as sort of like a distributed kind
of neuromodulator they're responsible
for making sure the ion concentrations
around the neurons are buffered properly
they take up neurotransmitters and may
respond to them as well they clearly
provide a lot of metabolic support to
their surrounding neurons regulate blood
flow and control the surrounding
circuitry interestingly when you focus
in on those really fine process of the
astrocytes and you look at where they
are relative to neurons there's has been
in this emerging concept tween I was
sort of the tripartite synapse we
usually think of a synapse of having a
presynaptic side and a postsynaptic side
but what been Barris mother's pointing
out is that thrown after every synapse
to the brain or just 80 or 90% of them
you can always find an astrocyte process
in sheathing that Center at least making
very close contact with it this
peripheral astrocyte process or
abbreviated PAP here and those
prophecies seem to if you look at the
proteins they had have the proteins
available to do a lot of the specialized
function you want to see to support a
synapse such as taking up excess
neurotransmitter like glutamate
recycling back glutamine to the
presynaptic side buffering calcium and
potassium but in any one aster site is
making these kinds of contacts - with up
to 10,000 synapses and we wondered
whether or not they might
so have some kind of local translation
at these peripheral processes so
Chrissie set out to test this process of
this question and to establish this
you'd want to know kind of establish
three things first for local translation
you were so like Stuart did that there'd
actually be ribosomes and mRNA present
in those processes second that active
translation is actually occurring that
they're not just there but they're
functioning and then you know that's
could all be true but still kind of be
boring that just sort of everything is
translated everything in a master sex
and the third thing what you wanted to
see was whether or not it's actually a
specific subset of mRNAs that are in
which time right so using microscopy at
the lights level we could already see
that while Mutchler with the neurons
well a lot of the signal these ribosomes
GFP mice in the astrocytes was in these
proximal large processes if you zoomed
in on the find processes here's the G FA
p+ large-caliber process you can also
see sort of coming away and dashed lines
little puncta GFP that suggested it was
getting out into the find processes as
well repeating this at the e/m level
with an anti gfp antibody developed with
kind of a DA be immune approximates
reaction Christy was able to actually
image individual asters that processes
wrapping a pre and postsynaptic neuron
component and see if the ribosomes were
indeed right out here in these
opposition's the ribosomes look like
they're there the GFP tag is there um
second we wanted to see if the mRNA was
out there the problem with just staining
mRNA and a brain of full of astrocytes
is the abstracts cover the entire brain
so it's a little bit like looking for
flakes of snow in a snow field so we
need some way to image individual
astrocytes so as you develop this method
where we do a p2 intracranial injection
of a diluted a a benign under GF ap
driving the chloroform and this is
create sort of a sparse label of
astrocytes in the brain allowing us to
image individual ones and sort of ignore
their neighbors and we use the same
trick for a few different experiments
first at the level of in situ
hybridization for a prominent mRNA in
neurons for the GL t1 transporter we
were able to show that those mRNAs also
make it out into these very violent
processes so ribosomes are there and
mRNAs next we want to see if translation
actually
so she may use that same prep of
sparsely labeled astrocytes and then a
biochemical transfer detection new
translation this is all published now in
PNAS 2017 so we make an acute slice from
one of these brains with sparsely
labeled astrocytes the same kind of
slice you would do for electric
physiology and we incubate it with pure
myosin which is an inhibitor of
translation that is a tRNA analog so it
binds to the extending nascent peptide
on translating ribosomes and the other
thing so it stalls translation but the
other thing it does is that it also
provides you an epitope so good
antibodies appear myosin you can now
detect that and identify where
translation was occurring when you gave
the drug so doing very short pulse
labeling slices this is what this looks
like you can see there's strong labeling
in the surrounding neurons because they
have they certainly have high levels of
translation properly arguably a bit
higher than the answer site but if we
use the GFP of the sparsely labeled
astrocyte as a mask we can also identify
translation going on specifically in the
astrocytes and this extends all the way
out as far as the processes go
so this is quantified here as the amount
of pure myosin at different distance
from the nucleus and you can see that it
extends it's not in the nucleus much but
it extends pretty much throughout the
cell body all the way up to these five
processors Robert Gamez are there and
they're translated are they translating
anything interesting and this is where
we took the methods that we had
originally developed for neurons and ask
the questions will they also work on
these astrocytes so we simply swapped in
the astrocyte line here at the early
step and asked whether or not so maybe
some of this peripheral astrocyte
process was Co fractionating and if so
could we at harvest time we're in April
and this is what I really knew we were
onto something which is that our first
look at that gene list and the
transcripts that were enriched in this
fraction and just kind of identifying
the top 10 or 20 or so and looking at
what those genes were looking back at
this cartoon from the review paper I
highlighted earlier for every one of
these functions we could find a gene so
here you know these these process
are supposed to take a glutamate here
are the two most highly expressed
glutamate transporters master sites that
were seen enriched out of these
processes there's a specific potassium
channel here there is the two enzymes
they're involved in recycling blue
tomato glutamine here so it was really
kind of compelling that we might have
actually uncovered an astrocyte local
translate time in addition we had some
things we haven't thought about ahead of
time but that makes sense so we have a
variety of motor kinesins and myosin
proteins it's there has been some
evidence from other labs that these
processes are modal at a relatively slow
rate like across circadian time for
example so this might this local
translation of these proteins might be
involved in kind of motility these
processes and then some things we didn't
expect like an entire pathway for
synthesizing fatty acids my best to make
new membrane or support neurons in some
way and if we do go term enrichment
maybe the categories have just talked
about or significantly enriched and
there's also some really interested us
interesting secreted proteins to things
here that are known to regulate
astrocytes play a key role in the
promotion of neuronal synapses and some
of those regulators of spent synapse
development where things we were seen as
locally detention locally translator so
it's a subset of memories that are
enriched there we then did a little bit
of work to try and identify what was
driving that Richmond of those things it
looks like in general the things that we
were seeing in rich there had longer
utrs and coding sequences they had a
more structured utr as well so we think
it's something in the untranslated
region this fits with what had been seen
in neurons and other systems where
motifs across a range of transcripts
they're found specifically in utrs
seem to be involved in regulating
localized translation so you'll often
have a motif in btro that's bound by
specific RNA binding protein and those
things can then interact with other
enzymes to change RNA localization
stabilization degradation translation
there Swiss Army knives they can often
do lots of different things so the next
thing that Chrissy did was to try and
identify specific motifs that might be
found more in the
which sequences the Matt control set of
depleted ones one that she found was
this motif that's supposed to bind the
QK RNA binding protein and she confirmed
that that's sort of a rich there and
we're doing a lot of a follow up
experiments now to determine that really
is driving the localized translation and
expression of these things and I might
save that for another another day but
I'm trying to give it to you out I've
convinced you least that these
astrocytes which would be also like
neurons have a regulated local
translation for specific transcripts I
think there's a lot of great questions
that to pursue there as far as whether
or not that's regulated activity can
independent peripheral processes do that
independently of one another or was it
do it aster site-wide is it required for
any particular biological function the
lab is interested in that anybody is
interested in studying those things feel
free to reach out and contact me so kind
of as a first step in understanding
whether or not we were interested
whether or not like local activity near
a synapse my modulate local translation
in the master site and we're starting to
design experiments around that but I
realized that nobody would actually even
looked whether or not activity in
neurons in general stimulates
translation and exercise so starting
with a bigger picture question first we
did a series of experiments to kind of
get a sense of whether that could be
true before we zoom in individual
processes so using this same system it's
nice because you can use pharmacology in
these slices and do a lot of fast
experiments so proceed in a range of
things that are thoughts uh stimulates
stimulate neuronal activity in these
slices or any like the activity of
neurons like BDNF and then look at what
happens to translation she also the
inhibition of activity through blockade
by TTX or combinations of TTX qcl
this is data from individual cells so
kind of 30 ish cells per group showing
what happens at baseline you have a
certain amount of translation in the
astrocytes as a negative control we can
block all translation show that signal
goes away and then she showed that
stimulating with things that should
depolarize neurons dramatically increase
the activity in astrocytes so it looks
like they're responding to that blocking
activity of neurons
some basic activity suppresses that
translation in the astrocytes and
blocking while stimulating gives you
sort of an intermediate phenotype which
says that some of the response to KCl in
the astrocytes is due to neuronal
activity and some leaders furthermore
BDNF also looks like it stimulates out
translation Astrid I was resisting we
did one additional set of experiments
and collaboration in key Zhang's who are
curious whether or not neurons were
required for this so with ye she's got a
nice culture system that can make
elaborate astrocytes in culture we
repeated this series of stimuli in
cultures that have no neurons now under
those circumstances neither TTX or KCl
alone had any effect on translation and
astrocytes so it seemed like that was
being routed through the presence of
neurons BDNF still have some confusion
Lee putting them both together did
create a significant effect we're still
puzzling that one out so astrocytes can
have a translational response to
neuronal activity we're turning get that
down to the level of individual perhaps
if we can sometime in the near future
and then kind of the last vignette I'm
going to talk about and what I have
about ten minutes left
yeah yeah the community listen ten I
guess the nice thing about doing this
online is that no question-and-answer
period so I get to eat all the time just
for my science right not just text me or
email me the questions if you guys have
them so this was led by a great postdoc
in the lab our sons Kota who is was kind
of also just a new method development
around trap so you know start by
reminding you guys about alternative
splicing so this is a the peptide
neurotransmitters eeen and this is to
remind you that the alternative splicing
is sort of an evolutionary solution to
creating more different kinds of
proteins by using the same size genome
so if you have a set of set of exons
that are that can be used to make a
particular protein one way you can make
more than one protein from the same set
is by having alternative splicing where
you use different sets of sets of exons
or even splice junctions with the same
exon to make different transcripts from
the same gene
this allows in this case there are two
different
peptides from the same gene there's also
I think that's kind of a widely
understood phenomenon this does you know
on average genes have I don't know three
to ten different splice isoforms but
there are individual examples that have
hundreds of different isoforms what I
wanted to talk about a little bit today
is also that there's another layer
regulation that can happen even after
splicing that I'm referring to call
alternative translation just and that's
parallel slicing so you know what if you
have a gene that has no alternative
splicing here's this c/ebp p gene which
has only one exon well there's still an
ability to generate diverse different
proteins out of that single transcript
by changing what part of it gets
translated this is what we're calling
alternative translation and this
particular gene is a classically studied
one in that regard where there's three
known protein isoforms that full-length
to laugh and a lip by so form and these
are mediated by in green different start
codons these are three different
methionine positions and depending on
which one gets used you can make shorter
and shorter versions of this protein and
that can have a clear functional
consequences from a review I'm kind of
showing the cartoon of this gene and
these different isoforms excuse me even
the sub ice-t friends of the lab this is
a this particular protein is a
translation factor or sorry excuse me a
transcription factor and it has
activation domains at the end terminal
and DNA binding and dimerization domains
at the C terminal and it works as a
dimer typically so when you have a
full-length protein this is an activator
of transcription because IDs activation
domains when you have this truncated
form it can dimerize but it doesn't have
any activation domains so it actually
works as a dominant negative on
transcription so the exact same gene can
act opposite functions depending on
which protein isoforms produced for the
same transcript another example of sort
of alternative translation when it's not
changing protein sequence is a sort of a
regulatory one and this comes from the
stress-related transcription factor atf
for this is another genome browser shot
showing the here's where the protein is
typically starting from this longer
transcript but the
actually a number of things that could
potentially be start codons that are in
the 5 prime UTR that are upstream of
that translation annotated translation
initiation shek 80 is and in classic
studies from southern birds lab he's
actually shown that these upstream runs
under certain circumstances can act as
decoys the rise scanning ribosome will
bind there and initiate at these
upstream open reading frames and
translate these products here that don't
seem to make a functional protein rather
they simply prevent access to the
primary translational initiation site
preventing translation of this protein
normally under certain circumstances in
this case cellular stress
phosphorylation of initiation factor can
change the preference for these upstream
sites allowing for translation of the
down of the accurate worker this is no
mechanism by which biology can regulate
translation in the main proteins the
transcript can be there waiting for some
kind of signaling event to allow for
translation through the mechanism of
having these decoys in the five prime
UTR and this can be assessed to some
extent using rabbit a variation ribosome
for printing and this is pointed out by
MOA Weissman again what you do is you
add a particular inhibitor of
translation or class of inhibitors that
stalled ribosomes after initiation but
allow them to progress if they're
already long gating and if you look at
ribosome footprints
after this without rum you get ribosomes
and some of these upstream sites but
then you also get ribosomes extending
into the protein if you add this drug
and allow time to occur the ribosomes
that are in the protein you long it off
and those that remain are those that are
sitting at initiation sites and that
allows you to see where initiation sites
were occurring in in the protein and
then this example actually this is their
data from ATF for from their paper you
can see the classic
upstream Orff's that have been
identified before they were able to
recapitulate now by using this method
the advantage being of this method now
is they could do this genome-wide
because it's using transcriptomic to
sort of evaluate all these lines so
using the same experimental design and
alluded to earlier with or without
stimulation cell culture
starting in culture because it's easy to
get
we can look specifically for these sort
of n-terminal variations using homo'
harrington
so both production of a normal protein
and annotated site upstream events that
might be in frame and extended and
terminal downstream events and frame and
extend truncate like the example of the
CBE PP or these out of frame upstream
events that could be making some kinds
of tea choice so that our Sun first kind
of repeated their experiments they've
done ania cells in the brain let's see
if many of the same sorts of things are
true and then to try to confirm that
these things actually work were making
protein or not and he identified a
variety of novel protein isoforms and we
just put this paper out I think a month
ago in cell reports so you can get more
data there so here's an example of some
of our traces from these ribosomes
footprinting and we can identify for
this one transcript actually quite a
number of Peaks that appear to be
translating including here's the
annotated translation initiation site
with a variety of new upstream ones one
of the surprises that I guess it was
truly ourselves is sort of for any given
transcript on average we're seeing at
least different three different
translation and initiation sites so this
is just the quite a lot of protein
diversity could be generated by this
mechanism and or these kind of decode
mechanisms and some transcripts had up
to 12 and at that point we almost
stopped counting beyond that we're
worried about our read depth being too
shallow but it's actually kind of the
minority that only had one translation
initiation site so for any given
transcript you're looking at there's a
lot more proteins being made or
potential proteins being made than you
would traditionally expect this is just
to show that many of these are in frame
but many of them are out of frame so on
average about half are in frame and half
her out and those that and they're also
events as in ghoulia saw that aren't
starting on 80 GS but other things that
are near cognates we also saw a lot more
data we confirmed a subset of these
working with the steam lab at Harvard to
do mass spec on similar cultures we
confirm that a subset of these are
actually making proteins so here's a
peptide
here's peptide evidence showing
that for this RT and one gene we
actually are seen a novel sort of 20 ish
amino acid extension where it's starting
from this upstream start codon changing
the n-terminal of the protein here's an
example where we had a downstream
initiation site and peptide that confirm
the existence of that sort of initiation
at the second death lining and not first
so we did a fair amount of biome from
EDX to try and understand why particular
trends if you have multiple translation
initiation sites why are some selected
over others
the Kozak sequence that sort of motif
around the start codon seem to have some
influence on it with the tendency of the
annotated one to have a stronger Kozak
than the DT is or ET is in terms of how
well it matches that canonical motif and
if you looked at how in general is it I
guess the same it also says that more RT
is was used the stronger the Kozak was
sort of a correlation there between
those things again with the annotated
one tendinitis stronger one
so when you were seen an annotated one
not being used to what extent we were
seeing the use of decoys like the
example that ATF 14 so we did see that
the stronger the Kozak sequence was
around one of the potential upstream T
is sites the less he used the annotated
translation initiation site so for if
they had kind of better scores you got
less usage that seems this decoyed
phenomenon is kind of general and can
explain you know there's negative
correlation here so it explains in
latina likewise the more of those decoys
you had the less you had translation at
their canonical site and the longer the
five hundy TR the less you had
translation you can combine all those
things together into a single model if
you add all those variables together you
can explain about 50% of the variance
and the annotated use of the annotated
one by these upstream events so we have
some idea of why you might be using less
or more of the annotated translation she
shouldn't say
contrast for the downstream months we
couldn't really explain much we know our
assumption was that maybe the ones that
had
dream initiation just had very weak
annotated start codons but that turned
out really not to explain much so what
kind of that's a bit of a mystery there
what's going on the next thing we looked
at is whether how do these things change
dynamically so are they regulated in
response to activity using that same KCl
simulation paradigm this is all of the
events we can measure well and we're
showing that in response to KCl a lot of
them shifted ribosomes from the decoy
zone of the main T is from or could see
but there are individual ones that went
the opposite direction moving to
upstream or downstream TAS as a response
to activities so Susan first the first
answer is that it's it is regulated the
second answer is that it seems to be
transcript specific Howard regulated
there's not one general rule for all and
the third thing we learn is that the
magnitude of this kind of looks like the
magnitude of alternative splicing so
shifts in ten to thirty percent not like
all-or-none kind of events but probably
the same kind of magnitude of biology as
what we see there here's some examples
of individual events there so here's
what stimulation this GF AP moves from
the annotated to a downstream one with
stimulation this HSP he checked protein
shifts to the annotate those are the
last thing darshan with that was in
addition to kind of these variations of
the n-terminal are their variations in
the c-terminal and what this has been
observed in a paper done it all also
associated with the Weiss would reap was
that occasionally when using Ramazan
foot protein you see this surprising
effect where a subset of ribosomes would
extend past the first stop codon into
the three prime UTR but stop at the
second stop codon phenomena called stop
codon read through to relatively
understudy and explained so could we see
this emerging as well so again I'll
remind you this is sort of a ribosome
footprints they usually ends at the stop
codon so we looked for instances where
we're seeing a pile of degrees beyond
that in this region between the first
and second stop codon and so map -
there's a connective control gene
doesn't have that but here's an example
a few things we found in the cultures
that did so here's a aquaporin four and
then dh1 both had
robust read-through but only until this
that second stock Twitter we wanted to
confirm this an independent system and
to see if it was sequence dependent so
we cloned those fragments out into a
reporter so she's taking this sequence
between the stop codons and drop it in
between two different flavors and
luciferase her order vector and then
measuring how much we got of the enzyme
activity out for the second gene with
positive controls including things that
basically were fusion proteins of no
stocks around or negative some lots of
stock clearance and we can see that
these sequences for aquaporin for and
and EH one were capable of supporting
read through all on their own
so it was just something about those
sequences themselves allow that stuff
could I read through to her so the next
thing we learned asked is does this
occur in vivo so that or is it just kind
of weird out effector cell culture and
is it cell type-specific and so here
what their son did and this is one of
those times when like one slide
represents to you know quite a lot of
work is that he figured out a way of
coupling our trap method which allowed
for cell type-specific capture ribosomes
with this ribosome 14 approach so
essentially digesting the mRNA while the
ribosomes are on the butt beads leaving
these fragments so now we can look at
this alternative translation in vivo in
the brain and cell type-specific way we
haven't done much with the n-terminal
variation yet because we take some guy
giving the drugs in the brain at the
right dose it's going to take some
optimization but he did focus on the SI
terminals to start with for this paper
and this is just showing for that
aquaporin foreign genes specifically
from their astrocyte line this is an IG
b browser shot I should update that but
here is the open reading frame here the
thing with no write interruptions until
you get to the first stop codon then
here's the second stuff going on and you
can see that you have read piling up in
[ __ ] between those two stop codons just
like in vitro me and the read-through
was probably occurring ledyba so he
focused for the remainder of the paper
on this aquaporin for transcript he'd
seen that's an essential water channel
highly expressed master sites it's
interesting because it can the knockout
can ameliorate or exacerbate stroked any
other model and it's a target for
autoimmune disease
mara myelitis opteka it also seems to
have an important role in potentially
clearing a beta from the brain that when
the mechanism by which it does that is
so controversial it's known to be
localized in a specialized process of
the aster site called the end foot's the
end foot is this part of the aster side
yeah but these astatine processes that
make contacts with synapses you also
have a portion that makes contact with
the blood vessels and this provides part
of the key blood brain barrier that
makes the brain sort of uniquely
specialized in terms of interaction into
vascular system for not reported for is
highly not only there is highly enriched
there and there seems to there's some
potential sort of peri vascular space
that's involved in clearance lymphatic
like clearance potentially in the brain
or normal some debate there this time I
don't care - it's the first thing that
darthon did was word and confirm that
this thing was actually making a protein
and made it without it so working with
people at cell signaling technology we
raised an antibody to that novel C
terminal extension sequence so if we're
adding amino acids meaning MIT that's
specific for those we call that
aquaporin for X or extended antibody
this is compared to a pan out before and
for here in green so the pan op report
for antibody does label blood vessels
this kind of structure here
it also labels all that basically the
surface of every astrocyte of some tends
to be as well the interesting thing
about this aqua port for X antibody is
that it actually seemed to specifically
localize to the blood vessel channel so
suggested there's read-through was
having to do with protein localization
they're super excited about it
we were pre rup free replicated aka
scoops by another lab on it shortly
after we got it you should check out
their paper to you they did some really
nice functional work
characterizing whether or not these
channels have normal flow and they did
it right human we did Mouse slightly
different same fundings on that part
this is dar sounds quantification
showing that the xform seems to be more
strongly parry vascular than the regular
port for antibody which of course is
going to label both the stuff at the end
feet and everything else the other thing
that darts online on the show is want to
know whether this reads
phenomena is regulated and so are
developing in strokes since I seem to be
involved in stroke after a stroke if you
look at the peri infarct region all of
report for its upregulated in the Glee
onic astrocytes but the aquaporin 4x is
actually operating in less that's
quantified here so it seems like really
there's some kind of differential
regulation between the two that's
possible and we looked across multiple
ways of inducing gliosis whether a
genetic lesion or a physical injury and
this seemed to always be true there
seems to be some regulation by closest
of this read-through phenomenon
suggestion is biologically here the
localization is functional and then this
suggestion is regulated and we're kind
of Adar sounds working on following that
up now as well as into relationship to
disease so this is kind of my take-home
messages for the day that I'm flashing
back to and the Galasso I was talking
about don't convince you is that there's
a whole layer of underappreciated
regulation in terms of alternative
translation and different proteins that
could be made from the same exact mRNA
sequence if you look for it and we found
this is just one a highlighted juice
aquaporin for but he found this
happening in about 1% of the protein of
the transcripts we could measure in the
brain and in the cell type specific
manner comparing neurons and glia so
this is sort of dozens of transcripts
this was happening too and we're
following up the ones we can and then
the last and most important slot is to
thank the people that did this work I
think I tried to highlight throughout
the people that were the bulk of the
astrocyte experiments talking today with
Chrissy and our son a couple of the
collaborative with a couple of
computational people in the lab they
wrote some more Amazon foot protein
steps children young and Allie Lake
there's an undergraduate who did a lot
of work on the activity-dependent work
in the rug scientist key and then this
is the whole lab who was real pleasure
to work with on all of our projects
including these and of course our
funders who made all of this possible
and our collaborators who make our lives
and our science better so that's what I
have today normally I would ask for
questions don't know there's been some
through the chats or anything else
there's nothing that like I have one or
two questions because you can just yeah
we switch it back to the other okay let
me get self arranged here okay thank you
very much it's pretty interesting
I learned a lot from like I haven't been
following this part of the whole thing
much I have one like basic question so I
don't know whether it makes sense or not
like you have been doing these various
transcription translations and all those
things like can you multiplex them mmm
me like yeah yeah you do like five six
of them are ten of them because in the
disease state what happens is some are
up some are low if you have considered
one like for an example as I must some
things go up some things go down like if
you can multiplex simultaneously this
farm is like kind of up here this like
ten oh yeah
the ribosome footprint in combined with
trap is all the transcripts at lunch as
long as you sequence deeply enough so I
was highlighting aquaphor and for but we
have those same measures genome-wide and
select all in the supplement you know I
tended for these papers you tend to like
have the discovery phase where you write
here's like all of the genes we found
and they're in this giant supplemental
how many other phase of like I can't
work on all of them so I've got a pick a
couple it's you can resume in and so I
might assume bit a little too fast but
yeah with with all of these methods the
local translation the ribosome for
protein combined with trap you're really
getting a genome-wide view of what's
going on
so you're multiplexing that way in terms
of just processivity like how many
samples can i handle at a time you want
to do this kind of thing with biological
replicates i think in a given day my
kind of a four to six sample number is
pretty good for like what you can do
trap on comfortably and not get
overwhelmed by the amount of samples
that you're handling and a good
experiment if you're comparing cell
types like n of two or three is actually
fine to see different cell types because
those are ten 50 fold differences a lot
of these things if you did any like nah
versus wild-type I think your end needs
to be more like 5 or 7 per group and in
a case probably you're talking like two
or three days and experiments to get and
get all your RNA in the freezer that's
just for the trap mark some of the
library prep any other method is easier
hard it could be another week to three
weeks depending on what you're doing
there but that's sort of standard
molecular biology handling twelve to
twenty samples at a time or robotics if
you get creative but we haven't had that
the need exactly to bring that alone
slash the funding to do you know one
hundred track experiments at once
proteins so if you can like since you
have the whole thing in there it's
basically how do you put those things
together and get five six of them
because that might give you more answer
the other thing Richardson do it I think
this is what you're alluding to is like
combining these different methods right
so you know can we put together the trap
method with the peripheral astrocyte
profile at the local translation method
with the ribosome footprint and get like
local production of isoforms in response
to activity so those are you just need
the right student he's really that kind
of tackle trying to harmonize those
things I think it's I think it's
feasible on paper and it would be really
cool and informative to do it yeah the
longer we do it the better we get at it
you know the experiment you know we have
some more and more kind of these pieces
in place to do these things too and so
you can scale up as you get you've been
through it more times
thank you very much thanks we have a
serious is forward interesting in this
anybody has questions feel free to email
me send all the emails out to people
like if they have any questions anything
they are looking for any positions they
will contact you immediate thank you
very much thank you